[موسيقى]
امور سياسيه
مستحيل الظروف الاجتماعيه يعني
بالسنوات
تقريبا
التعيينات مثل ما يقول قوه
يوصفوا نحن مثل الارض احنا المكونات
الاصليه احنا كيف احنا كيت احنا كيت انتم
اللي بيناتهم انتم اللي عمرتوا انتم اللي
عانيتم لك احنا محرومين
وانا عندي هسه حوالي خمس شهادات قاعده
بالبيت
عيون الكثير طيله الفترات السابقه وعلى
الحكومات المتعاقبه من اهمال كبير
وعدم اعطاهم حقوقهم المشروعه التي كفلتها
القوانين سواء هذه كان قوانين وضعيه من
القانون العراقي او من قوانين الامم
المتحده القوانين التي تخص حقوق الانسان
كانت معاناه كبيره همم سواء في العهد
الانظمه السابقه او في العهد الحالي كنا
نتامل خيرا بعد عام 2003 ان يكون هنالك
تغيير كبير واعطاء حقوق
وبناء كبير الى كل بنيه التحتيه العراقيه
كمان تعلم بان العراق هو تنوع دينيه
ومذهبي كبير همم هذا التنوع نزار العراق
وكل هذه المكونات الدينيه تظهر فيه
ولكن عندما يكون هناك سيطره من قبل
المكونات الكبرى
عندما يقصد تقسم المناصير وتقسم الثروات
وتقسم كل شيء الى ثلاثه مكونات اللي هم
اخواننا السنه والشيعه والاكراد
ويكون غامض باقيه الحقوق الاخرى للمكونات
الدينيه الاخرافه هذا اجحاف كبير